the plate is still warm so you just want
to hold it like the entire plate is mine
hey guys my name is brian hi my name is
michelle hi my name is kathleen hi i'm
john i am chinese american i was born
and raised in brooklyn new york my
ancestors are all from china i'm from
maryland my parents are chinese
immigrants and they're from fujo china i
am born and raised in china i came here
since college i was born and raised in
ohio my parents are from shandong but
yeah i love all types of dumplings i
don't really discriminate i'm expecting
everyone to bring some fire dumplings to
be honest i hope they like mine i have
no expectations but i know it would be
great i grew up eating chinese food at
home but it didn't feel like it was
something that i wanted to to do i
wanted to make pizza or mexican food or
something like that it didn't become
something that i wanted to make for
myself until i grew up and dumplings
just hasn't ever taken place until
no it's a pork and chive dumpling it's
pretty straightforward simple there's
nothing crazy going on sauce wise it's
just sesame oil and laughter mock as
long as it's edible like we're good here
today it smells so good i think this is
the chives dumpling is it pork i can
definitely see pork some type of green
it could be green onion the folds are
missing a little bit it just kind of
looks like he just folded the skin in
half i'm excited to try them it's a lot
of filling which is good but looking at
the sauce it looks like it's almost like
pure oil i don't know how much of this
sauce i should dip
that is pure sesame oil so
can i only eat one so the skin's like a
bit sticky this is some ham good
dumplings sometimes there's a roof in my
mouth a little bit a thin skin most
likely store-bought skin so you can't
really go wrong the meat is very well
seasoned i think the ratio is perfect
and the meat is really nicely chopped
the chives are cut a little bit thick i
definitely like how these taste for sure
and the sauce i think i like it a lot
but i think i would have appreciated a
little bit more spice i wish it was just
like a little bit more flavor this is
hard because this is the first one i
don't i don't want to go too high but i
also don't want to go too low i would
give it a
8 out of 10. maybe a six or seven out of
ten depending on how the rest of the
dumplings are generally speaking i think
these are above average overall 8.5 and
i think it's pretty good
i did learn about dumplings growing up i
feel like it was kind of like a family
thing when we made it you know when you
make it with love and you put intention
into it it tastes so much better it's so
cheesy it's tough he's literally
laughing right now i just made simple
dumplings with just pork and shrimp and
there's bamboo and then marinated in the
soy sauce
and then the sauce is a really regular
soy sauce so nothing special about that
i can't make any promises about the
flavor i'm so sorry to my father he's
gonna watch this he's gonna be like how
dare you i feel like this player
dumplings is one of those we get really
emotional for it's like your mom or your
grandma made it for you you just want to
hold it like the entire plate is mine
they look ten times better than mine
they look really nice presentation wise
when you have the pleats rolled up more
than three or four times you can tell a
lot of skill and precision was put into
the dumplings you see those folds damn
my ancestors would rise from their
graves and say how good it is
it's good it's very good these are
really good there is something really
crunchy in here either it's fungus or
it's bamboo i can really taste each
individual ingredient can i eat another
one there's a lot on it
on the scale of how many dumplings i
could eat of this yeah probably 15. if i
had this at a restaurant i would be like
i want two of those skin not too doughy
not too sticky the only thing that i
think there's room to improve on is
probably the skin i like my skin's a
little bit more doughy the filling to
wrap ratio is very good in my eyes i
could not make dumplings like this
myself only improvement maybe i would
have put something like slightly spicy
in it the sauce isn't my favorite kind
just tastes like soy sauce it's ten out
of ten i'll give it an eight and a half
out of ten i think these are a solid
eight and a half out of ten i i'll i'm
down i'm down i would have wanted to
come to this challenge saying that you
know i've made dumplings for all of my
life we do this every single year i've
never made dumplings before even though
i was born and raised in china i made a
pork dumpling
with fungus hamur and then there's
shiitake mushrooms as well as leeks i
try to make it the traditional way where
it's like you fold it pretty but i
couldn't necessarily do it so i made two
ufos on the side i hope you guys enjoy
the heavy on the meat ratio dumpling
save me one more time i dare you
these look so amazing this one is a
really weird shake the dumplings look
interesting doesn't it kind of look like
like an empanada or something like it
looks like a ufo it looks like two
dumplings just [ __ ] mashed together
am i allowed to curse yeah it's
personality to the dumpling
wow these are so good this is just a
really chunky boy the whole point of the
dumpling is so you can eat it all in one
bite if you want to i've never had a
dumpling that says flavored i think
there's like mushrooms in here there's
mushroom in here i like the mushrooms
when you chew it it spreads out so i
think this is chopped really nicely
three out of ten because it doesn't
really fully resemble a dumpling the
taste is there but at the end of the day
like it's a dumpling challenge taste
wise i think they taste fine the sauce
really complements these dumplings but
the weirdly shaped dumpling that's gotta
be a minus i would rate this an eight
out of ten i would give this a seven
and i'm kinda scared because i i don't
cook that often to be honest especially
not chinese cuisine just because i'm
always worried if i'll do it justice i
went for a spicy wonton recipe just pork
and shrimp and i made a separate spicy
sauce to drizzle over it's just soy
sauce cane sugar some chili oil garlic i
tried really hard and i hope everyone
likes it i'm not sure if they're
dumplings they look more like wontons i
love me some wontons are wontons
dumplings
in the dictionary that you think i love
the garnishing the display immaculate
immediately yes he or she put sauce on
it already i appreciate the garnish a
lot i love the garnish love the plating
i think the black plates really make the
yellow pop so whoever did this very
creative
[Music]
okay
it's a little spicy
wow
that was the best bite of food i've had
today this is the first dumpling that
literally is all meat on the inside the
meat is so good i think there's shrimp
in here so much flavor very well
seasoned the good flavor is a green
onion the sauce on the bottom with all
the garnishes it just made it all come
together very good i really like the
sauce that was really good actually i
would eat this for breakfast lunch and
dinner it's a little unfair to the rank
of wonton versus the dumpling because
they're literally different things but
if a little bit lacks on the rules here
this is a 9 out of 10. i mean i'll give
it a nine out of ten the only reason why
it's not a ten gotta follow the rules no
mercy and because that's the only way i
come back i don't even need to judge it
i just feel like i'm just enjoying the
dish and that's why i feel like this is
a ten out of ten i'm happy that people
enjoyed my dumplings i definitely
googled and i was like are wontons
dumplings google says that wontons are
dumplings didn't really try to go too
overboard with anything kind of just mix
stuff for the sauce until i thought it
was spicy and tasty enough and here we
are now so this was really fun
[Music]